Let us introduce
the error measures
we used in building
the analytics models.
We of course used R squared,
but we also used other measures.
Next measure, the
so-called "penalty error,"
is motivated by the fact
that if you classify
a very high-risk patient
as a low-risk patient,
this is more costly
than the reverse,
namely classifying
a low-risk patient
as a very high-risk patient.
Motivated by this, we
developed a penalty error.
And the idea is to use
asymmetric penalties.
The graph here--
so it's a matrix--
where this is the outcome
and this is the forecast.
For example, whenever we
classify a low-risk patient
as high-risk, we
pay a penalty of 2,
which is a difference of 3 minus
1, the difference in the error.
But inversely, when you
classify a bracket 3 patient
as bracket 1 patient,
this is double.
The cost-- the penalty--
is double the amount.
So you observe that the off
diagonal penalties are double
the corresponding penalties
in the lower diagonal.
To judge the quality of the
analytics models we developed,
we compare it with a baseline.
And the baseline is
to simply predict
that the cost in
the next "period"
will be the cost in
the current period.
We have observed that as far
as identification of brackets
is concerned, the
accuracy was 75%.
So namely, whenever we predict
that the risk is bracket 3--
indeed it is bracket 3--
this happens 75% of the time,
and the penalty error--
the average penalty
error of the
baseline-- was 0.56.